Thank you very much.
Thank
you all for coming and thank
you for the invitation.
When someone from Google says that
your publications are countless,
it really means something.
Uh,
actually I wanted to say that
I'm very grateful to Google,
not only a for inviting me,
but because you give me my best way of
impressing people when I am trying to
blow their minds about my podcasts,
which is a,
I tell them about it and they say,
where can I find it? And I say,
just Google the phrase
history of philosophy.
And after Wikipedia I'll be the first hit.
And they were like,
no way.
Um,
I also sometimes try to impress people
by telling them how many times it's been
downloaded,
but I think if I told you the number
it probably wouldn't impress you,
so it won't bother. Okay. So, um, I was
asked to come speak about this book.
This is a little slide I like to
call shameless self promotion.
So I republish this,
uh, last year, I guess.
And it's a very short introduction to
philosophy in the Islamic world that was
published by Oxford University press.
And nowadays when I'm
asked what areas I work on,
I usually say late ancient philosophy
and philosophy in the Islamic world.
And that's a little bit of a mouthful.
And in fact,
when I was talking to the editors at Upi
about what to call the book, they said,
well,
can't we just call it Islamic philosophy
if that would be a lot easier and maybe
easier to sell? And I said, no, we can't.
And I want to first of all explain why.
So why is it called that?
Why is it called philosophy
and Islamic world?
There's really been a kind of debate
about what to call this topic.
Arabic philosophy or Islamic philosophy
as long philosophy is kind of the
obvious thing to call it because most of
the philosophers who leap to mind from
this tradition to the extent that any
philosophers at all leap to mind are
Muslim.
And also a big role in this tradition is
of course played by the context of the
chronic revelation.
So a lot of the thinkers in the
tradition are in fact sort of using
philosophical ideas to interpret the
Koran or respond to ideas from the Quran.
Uh, but I think actually in
a way, although that's true,
and I wouldn't for a moment deny it,
it's maybe prejudges the tradition as
one that's primarily about responding to
the Quran so that we assume that any
philosopher who was working in the Islamic
world would necessarily have been mostly
interested in using philosophy to,
for example,
prove that God exists or prove that
revelation as possible or prove that
Mohammed was really a profits.
And that the things he said are true.
There are certainly thinkers who were
very interested in that project and we're
even primarily motivated by doing that.
But that doesn't apply to all philosophers
who worked in the Islamic world.
And especially,
it doesn't apply to philosophers who
worked in the Islamic world who weren't
Muslim. And in fact, it turns out
that there were quite a few of these.
So just to give some examples.
Um,
the people who originally translated
Greek philosophical works into Arabic.
And I'll say more about
that in just a moment.
We're mostly Christians because they
were either from Syria or from of Syrian
extraction. This is what's
going to pass for, uh,
you know, rip from the
headlines. Relevance in my
talk, they were from Syria. Uh,
and the,
the,
the reason why they were the ones you
could turn to for translating Greek works
into Arabic is that there was a living
tradition in Syrian Christian monasteries
of working with Greek texts and
translating them into Syriac,
which is another Semitic language and
us a lot closer to Arabic. Then, um,
then Greek was,
so they played an important role in that
transmission of Greek philosophy into
the Islamic world's.
Uh,
and then after that you have
more Christians who engage
with these translations.
So a good example is a group that we
sometimes called the Baghdad Aristotelians
who lived in the 10th century,
uh,
and they were Christians and
known in this metropolis,
the center of the Islamic empire of
Baghdad as experts and Aristotelian
philosophy. Another example, and maybe
a more prominent example in a way,
is that a lot of important
Jewish philosophers have
lived in the Islamic world,
including the most famous and
important ever Jewish philosopher,
unless you count spinosa which
topic of a whole another talk,
but with Spinosa Jewish philosopher,
but even perhaps more famous than it's
Moses [inaudible] who lived in the 12th
century,
was born in Islamic Spain.
And when conditions became
unfavorable for Jews moved to Cairo.
So when I wrote the,
the Vsi,
and in general,
when I do research on this area,
I always try to make a big deal about
the fact that if you're going to study
philosophy from this cultural context,
you have to realize that some of
them were Christians and Jews,
and you shouldn't therefore call
the topic Islamic philosophy.
That would just be kind of
bizarre, right? In fact,
it would be more appropriate to call
medieval European philosophy Christian
philosophy than to call this Islamic
philosophy because in medieval Christian
Europe, almost all thinkers were in
fact Christians. But we don't do that.
So I don't call it as long philosophy.
Uh,
sometimes people have suggested
calling an Arabic philosophy,
and this is in part to
highlight something I just said,
which is that philosophy in the Islamic
world more or less kicks off with the
Greek Arabic translation movement
in the ninth century and century.
A lot of you are engineers.
I should mention that this
isn't just about philosophy.
That translation movement also
renders many works of science and even
engineering into Arabic.
So you have works by Ptolemy,
Euclid and other mathematicians
who are translated into Arabic.
They translated not necessarily
everything they could get their hands on,
but an astonishing amount to the point
that, for example, Aristotle who for them,
just as in medieval Europe was
the most important philosopher.
They could read pretty much all the
Aristotle we can read. But in Arabic,
um,
sometimes you might hear if you kind of
know anything about the importance of
philosophy in the Islamic world,
one of the things that you might know
is that Europeans got their hands on
people like Aristotle
through the Islamic world.
So the idea would be Greek philosophy
was translated into Arabic in the ninth
and 10th centuries.
And then it was,
the Arabic versions were
translated into Latin around 1200.
Um,
and as you'll see,
that's going to be an important feature
of the tradition that I'm going to talk
about later on that translation
into Latin around 1200. Um,
and so the thought would be,
oh,
well the reason we can read Aristotle is
because his works were translated into
Arabic and then that from there into
Latin and it kind of medieval version of
Chinese whispers.
Um,
that's actually not true because if you
think about it, we have aerosol in Greek,
we don't have to read
him in Arabic and Latin.
So actually we get Plato and
Aristotle from the Byzantine Empire,
which is basically the remnants of the
Roman Empire after had collapsed in the
west. It survived in the east
and they still have plenty there.
There are manuscripts of Plato and
Aristotle that still exists today.
That's how we can read them in Greek.
But although,
although it's not true that the Greek
has completely lost for these guys,
there are some ancient philosophical
and scientific works that are only
preserved in Arabic.
And it is certainly true that for a
while in the medieval Christian world,
their primary access to ancient philosophy
was through the Arabic tradition.
And they used Muslim philosophers as
commentators and guides to understanding,
uh, figures like Aristotle. Okay.
So this whole fact that Arabic plays
a crucial role in the transmission of
knowledge about science and
philosophy from the ancient world.
So ancient Greece and then the
Roman empire into the Islamic world.
That's certainly true.
And so an advantage of calling this field
Arabic philosophy is precisely that.
I actually am the co editor of an earlier
book called the Cambridge companion to
Arabic philosophy,
which I would now call the,
I would out wish I had called actually
the Cambridge companion to philosophy and
Islamic world. But this is what we
were thinking. Well, we call it that.
We were thinking it's either or Arabic
and we don't want to call it Islam Salami,
so we have to call it Arabic. And this
seemed like a good rationale for it.
But as we actually already admitted
in the introduction to that book,
uh,
this is actually quite misleading.
So the maybe the most misleading thing
about it is that it suggests that all
philosophical and scientific literature
in the Islamic world was written in
Arabic, which just
isn't true. So actually,
especially if you as you go
on into the later period,
and I'll be saying more
about that in a moment. Um,
a lot of philosophical literature from
the Islamic world is written in Persian
and there are other languages too where
they write a philosophy. So for example,
Syriac which I've already mentioned,
so I'm actually not very happy with
Arabic philosophy anymore either.
Arabic philosophy has one other problem,
which is that whenever
you say Arabic philosophy,
people then come up to you and
various self righteously say,
oh, but you do know that most
of them weren't Arabs. Right?
Which is true actually.
So a lot of the major figures
from the Islamic world,
we're not ethnically Arabs,
but we're from Central Asia,
including [inaudible] who as we'll
see as the most important figure of in
philosophy of the Islamic world.
But I just think that this is a,
this just shows that people don't know
English because in my opinion Arabic is a
language,
people aren't Arabic people are Arab.
I don't know what you
all think about this.
But to me as in sort of native speaker,
that's what Arabic and heroin means.
So this is to me a sort of,
it's sort of a fallacious reason
not to call it Arabic philosophy,
but it's really annoying to keep
getting people who keeps me,
well you know that they weren't
all Arabs so I've just done a lot,
I don't really want to deal with it.
Um,
there was actually another phrase
which is sort of sort of term of art,
which has been developed within
the field of Islamic studies,
which is the so called Islamic hate
Islamic hate would mean the geographical
regions under Muslim Dominion.
And that's really what I mean.
So I would call it Islamic hate philosophy
if I thought people would know what
the heck I was talking about.
But if I take it that, I mean,
if this had been called, notice how
I keep getting back to this slide.
I mean as an American emoney,
I'm a born marketer. I mean,
imagine if it was called
Islamic hate philosophy.
You'd have no idea what it
was about, right? Like what
does that supposed to mean?
So I don't say as long as Kate, I say
philosophy and Islamic world. Okay.
Now this is a little slide I like to
call shameless self promotion part two.
Um, if you actually look at the
bottom of this slide, that's the,
that's where you get if you
Google history of philosophy. Um,
so I've been running a podcast since 2010
whose aim is as it says at the top of
the books to cover the entire history of
philosophy without any gaps in 20 to 25
minute episodes. So it starts with the
pre socratics, the Greek philosophers,
and it goes until I get hit by a bus,
uh,
or meet some other and, or I get
to now. So sometimes people say,
well, what will you do? Like when you run
out of history of philosophy. And I say,
well, I can just like cover whatever
it was just published that week.
Um, it comes out once a week, every
Sunday. And um, as we already heard, it's,
uh,
to episode 273 I think there is also
about 40 episodes on Indian philosophy,
which I've been doing with,
um, [inaudible] and canary.
So one of the important features of
the project is to cover philosophy in,
in other cultures. Um, and,
and also to cover philosophy in a way
that doesn't just mean talking about the
major figures of philosophy.
Um,
so this is kind of introduction
to this wider project.
Oh,
and I should,
maybe I should explain the relevance to
the very short introduction is that in a
way that very short introduction is kind
of like an introduction to the material
that I covered much more,
uh,
in depth in this book because this book
is about five times as long as the other
one, cause it's without any gaps. Okay.
So what does it mean to do the history
of philosophy without any gaps? Well,
if you think about how,
if you sort of think about what
the history of philosophy means,
so none of you are philosophers
or professional philosophers,
but you've all heard of some philosophers,
right?
And if you conjure in your
mind who is a philosopher,
everyone sort of think of a philosopher.
Don't think of me,
think of just a kind of
generic philosopher. So
you're all thinking of a man,
probably you're thinking of a white guy,
you're probably even thinking of an
older white guy with a beard, right?
So you're basically thinking of someone
who looks like God on the chop, on the,
on the ceiling of the
Sistine Chapel, right? Uh,
and to be fair,
there are,
there have been plenty of white guys
with beards who are philosophers.
And if in fact, if you start thinking,
who are some famous philosophers?
Like if,
if we,
if I spent the rest of the time of this
talk asking you to name philosophers,
I'm sure you would all come up with plenty
of names that you might come up with.
Plato, Aristotle,
Socrates, Thomas Aquinas,
Descartes' comments,
Leiden.
It's Bertrand Russell Vichtenstein,
right?
These are all names that are
presumably known to all of you. If not,
you can Google them. Google humor. Um,
so,
uh,
and of course these are all like huge
figures in the history of philosophy.
And when I get to them, I give them
extra coverage. So for example,
Plato and Aristotle got something
like 15 episodes a piece.
And when I get to content,
God knows how many episodes that will
take me to cover him as I actually am
already sort of getting night sweats,
wondering how I'm possibly
going to adequately deal
with Conduent. I get to the,
to him in the podcast,
but especially because I work
in sort of more or lesser known,
let's say, uh, areas of
the history of philosophy.
It's important to me to try to
communicate the idea that the history of
philosophy is not just these brilliant
people who turn up every few centuries
and apparently, um, sometimes
after a long period of nothing.
So if you think about the list I just
gave you, Socrates, Plato, Aristotle,
Thomas Aquinas,
that's literally almost 2000 years
that I jumped over there because,
uh,
Socrates,
Plato and Aristotle are fifth and
fourth century BC and Thomas Aquinas is
anybody
close,
13th century eight d as
he died and the 1270s.
And if we played this game
again and I said, okay,
name me some philosophers who live
between Aristotle and Aquinas,
it would be a very short
discussion probably,
unless you've been
listening to my podcasts,
because I've done hundreds of episodes on,
on what happened in, in that gap. Okay.
If you, and if you think
about that, I mean, let's just
step back and to get that,
that a little bit more, that's more
than half of the history of philosophy.
I mean, chronologically, of course,
the closer we get to the current day,
the more text there is that survives.
So we have much more from the 17th century
that we have from the 12th century.
But we have a lot of information about
philosophy pretty much in an unbroken
line stemming from the,
the most ancient of the ancient
Greeks all the way up to now.
Um,
and of course it's not one single line
because it's actually multiple lines
moving through multiple cultures,
uh, and sometimes independently.
So Islamic philosophy or philosophy in
the Islamic world as I was saying before,
draws from Greek philosophy.
Um,
but there's also philosophy in
ancient India in ancient China,
which is basically independent
of Greek philosophy,
although that's sometimes dispute it,
but it's primarily independent even if
there is some filtering of ideas back and
forth. And there's also, um,
philosophical traditions.
There's this whole philosophical tradition
of Africa, of South America, et Cetera,
which never gets covered in
courses on history of philosophy.
So I'm trying to cover all
of this in the podcast.
I've already done philosophy Mia
Islamic worlds and I'm now doing Indian
philosophy with a coauthor name,
Jeanette and Guarneri next year with
someone named Chico Jeffers who works in
Canada. I'll be starting to
cover African philosophy,
including the flood philosophical
movements in the African diaspora.
And I'm hoping to do Chinese philosophy
after that. And then who knows. Um,
so one other thing I should mention
about not having any historical gaps is
that, as I said, when you imagine like
a famous philosopher, you imagine woman,
sorry, you can imagine a man, right?
But there have been plenty of
female philosophers and want, to me,
one of the most important kind of
implications of the project is alongside
covering philosophy from other cultures.
You cover female philosophers and you
don't cover them because you're being
politically correct or something.
You cover them because they're there and
you're covering the entire history of
philosophy and there's why would
you skip them? Right? So, um, I,
especially in the medieval period,
I've been able already to give a lot of
coverage to individual female thinkers
like Hildegard of Bingen method might've
book Marguerite poets who is there on
the left. Um, Christine [inaudible]
design, who's there on the right too.
I haven't gotten to yet, but I will. Um,
and I think that's Christine is on. Um,
so that's a real advantage I think of
the project and the way I'm doing it.
Okay. So, um,
for the rest of the time I want to sort
of narrow in now on philosophy and the
Islamic world and tell you about three
kinds of implications of doing it this
way. Um, on this topic.
So of course in a sense like covering
philosophy in the Islamic world already at
all is sort of filling a gap because the,
there are arguably no truly famous
philosophers from the Islamic world,
famous in the sense that Descartes
and played out her famous.
So almost everyone has heard
of Descartes and Plato.
Very few people have heard of more
than one or two Muslim philosophers.
Even you've heard of anyone you might've
heard of avid Ascena or a varies at the
center lived, um, from the 10th to
the 11th century. He died in 10 37,
a very always lived in
twins, 12th century, uh,
Islamic Spain and is the most important
medieval commentator on Aristotle.
Um,
and it varies is an interesting figure
because he's bound up with a kind of
narrative that you will often hear
about philosophy and the Islamic world,
which is that it flourishes with the
Greek Arabic translation movements.
And then it ends around the
end of the 12th century,
and it may be even ends at a very
specific, it actually ends on one day,
namely the day that Avera has died and
he died in 1198 right at the end of the
12th century. So the end,
if you think about it,
this is in a way a very convenient
narrative because the thought would be,
oh, well, Greek philosophy
was invented in Greece.
Actually it already existed in
China and India before that.
But let's leave that aside. And maybe
Egypt as well, but let's leave that aside.
So it begins in Greece,
the Roman Empire collapses.
Ono Philosophy is dead.
Oh No,
it's not because the Muslims come along
and save it and translate it into Arabic.
And then having fulfilled their historical
destiny by carrying the torch of
philosophy for three or four centuries,
they then pass it on to the Medieval
Christians who translated into Latin.
And then you get Thomas Aquinas,
scholasticism,
the renaissance and et cetera.
Um,
so one of the things I want to say and
emphasize a lot in both the podcast and
the very short introduction
is that this is just not true.
And that this whole story
about philosophies basically
ending around 1200 in the
Islamic world is a kind of meth.
I just checked the time. Um,
so that's one thing I want to say.
Another thing I want to sort of narrow
in on a bit more is to say more about
that Christian philosophers
I was mentioning before,
just as an example of what I was
saying earlier, which is that um,
this is kind of an ekin
ecumenical historical
phenomenon is not only the story
of Muslims using philosophy
to understand the Koran.
And the last thing I want to do just
briefly say something about, um,
Islamic theology,
which is a kind of test case
for my approach of including
absolutely everything
you might want to include in philosophy,
in the history of philosophy. Okay.
So first something about philosophy
of the later Islamic world.
Here's a map which shows the three,
actually not all of,
but most of the cause, the Ottoman Empire
is cut off there, but the three later,
uh,
empires in the Islamic world.
So these are the empires that exist
around the time of early modern Europe.
So around the time of the enlightenment
or the late Renaissance and
enlightenment. So like Descartes'
live minutes, that period,
this is what the Islamic world looks
like and moving up into the 17th,
18th centuries.
And if you look at that math,
you can see that it's pretty damn
big, right? Um, incidentally,
for those who don't know,
the clash between Sunni and Shiite Islam
today is traceable to some extent to
the fact that the Ottoman Empire,
the green bit is Sunni and the
south of an empire, the red, pink,
orange, but is a Shiite. So when the
[inaudible] came to power in Iran,
they, um, they sort of
turned Iran Shiite or, um,
made sure that Iran would stay
shy and it still is today.
And Muslims also had
control over much of India,
and there were philosophers
and all three of these areas.
Notice that we're way past
the 12th century here.
Here's a selective list of some
philosophers who lived after 1200. Um,
okay, fuck. At the end of that, I
was, he didn't live much after 1200,
but I put him on because he's a really
important and interesting figure in the
history of philosophical theology
that I'll be talking about later on.
But Ozzy and twosie or both
commentators on the center,
and because Dune is who you might've
heard of actually is a very famous a
theorist of history and wrote this amazing
history of the Islamic world where he
prefaces it with an explanation of
how civilizations rise and fall.
Um,
the school of Shit Oz,
which is exists just before the rise of
the south of ids in Iran was a kind of a
group of Addison and philosophers who
argued about the interpretation of his
works.
Moolah Sadra is an importance later.
Mystic philosopher who
lives in the south of it,
empire cut to genove is,
uh, an important Ottoman,
a philosopher data. She,
Ku is a really amazing guy.
He lived in Mughal India and he was a
prince who was assassinated or actually
had, had put on trial and killed by his
brothers to get him out of the line of
succession.
And he was a kind of scholar who was
fascinated with ancient Indian thoughts.
So he translated the opening shots and
wrote a book called the confluence of the
two oceans where he argued that the
teachings of the Koran as sort of filtered
through Sufism and the teachings
of the ancient Indian scriptures,
like the punish Hud's actually
amounted to the same teachings.
So he's quite interesting. Um, if
I had a body is another later, um,
uh, Mocha or Indian
rather a philosopher. Um,
and then I put on Mohammed Abdul who
is an interesting turn of the century
philosopher and mentioned fats in my
mind now Niecy because she's one of the
more interesting female
thinkers from the last century.
One of the problems I actually ran into
when I was doing philosophy Islamic
world is that I really want it to cover,
as I said before,
I want it to cover female
thinkers in the Islamic world.
And it's not a very good picture there.
So you can,
you find some interesting female thinkers
over the last hundred and 50 years or
so. Um, prior to that,
there are quite a few female
scholars in the Islamic world,
but not anyone who you
could really designate as a
philosopher as far as I know.
But if anyone has a counter example,
I would love to hear it. Okay. So, um,
the point of that was just,
sorry, before I leave this,
so the point of that was just,
I mean in a way I'm,
I can just show you that this narrative
of decline is wrong by saying, well,
here are some people that
the narrative leaves out. Um,
maybe I should say that there is actually
a cause you might be sitting there
thinking, well, hang on a second with
these people all exist. Then why,
why is it that when we pick up like a
Bertrand Russell's history of philosophy
or actually pretty much almost any
textbook on the history of philosophy,
if it bothers dimension, philosophy,
the Islamic world at all, it says, well,
it ends around 1200.
Why do we get that idea if,
what's with all these people? So
how did this happen? And the answer,
it goes back to something I said earlier,
which is the Arabic Latin
translation movement.
So remember I said that
happened around 1200.
It was mostly in Spain where the
Islamic and Christian worlds, we're, um,
we're confronting one another and it
actually even involved collaboration
between Christian, Muslim and Jewish
scholars who would sort of team up to,
uh,
translate things from Arabic into Latin.
And the effect of that was to
translate not just things like that,
not just Greek works like Aristotle,
but also works by a Muslim philosophers
like avid, avid, Santa and Avera ways.
So the death of philosophy in the Islamic
world to some extent is an illusion
created by the date of
that translation movements.
Because what it meant was that anyone who
lived after that or too far east to be
translated around 1200 in Spain
was just unknown in Europe.
And because they were unknown in Europe,
they played no role in influencing
people like Aquinas and more generally a
medieval scholasticism.
And that further amend that in the
19th and 20th century when modern day
scholars turned their attention to
look at philosophy, the Islamic world,
they thought, well, what we need
to do is study, have a Senate,
and a Vero is they ride the red them in
the medieval Latin translation or they
even learned Arabic and
read them in the original,
but they weren't interested in looking
at later if the thinkers who had no
impacts on Europe like these people.
Uh,
so in a way that tradition splits.
And until very recently,
most scholars have only been interested
in the kind of line of medieval
philosophy or line of Islamic philosophy
that gets received in the medieval west.
Okay. So Christian philosophers,
um, like I said, um,
one of the most important roles of
Christians in the philosophical tradition
I've been describing is the translation
of works from Greek into Arabic.
And I just wanted to
mention a few examples. Um,
so there's this guy who night in is huck,
who was from Iraq and his son was named,
is huck even a nine,
if it means son of,
and it's actually this sort of confusing
naming practice is quite common
unfortunately. Um, and
they're very interesting. A
couple of guys. So who nine,
uh, was raised to speak, be able to
speak classical Greek and his family.
So he tells a story about being told
to recite homer as a child to impress
visitors to their home,
which I'm sure worked.
And he was a specialist
in medical literature.
He translated the works of
the late ancient medical
authority gallon from Greek
into Arabic or from Greek into Syriac.
Um,
and then he would often have an assistant
translate the Syriac into Arabic
because that's easier. And his son
is [inaudible] nine was one of the,
probably the greatest translator
of Aristotle into Arabic.
So they're kind of a one family factory
for rendering Greek works of philosophy
and science into Arabic. Um,
and they're both Christians. Uh,
there are other Christians around the
same time who collaborate with Muslims,
with the Muslims,
basically paying them and also telling
them what they want translated.
One of the interesting things to look at
is w what things they translate and how
early. So for example, they make,
one of the choices they make is that
early on they translate works that will
help them engage in
dialectical disputation.
And the idea here,
it seems to be that they don't want the
Christians to be the only people who
know how to make good arguments because
then they'll lose in the public debates
over whether Islam as
better than Christianity.
So ironically they pay Christians to
translate books to give them the kind of
argumentative weapons to
argue with Christians.
And a good example of this
actually is, um, yeah,
he had been id who is a really fascinating
figure for whom we have a lot of
works, including a bunch of works that
were only just discovered in a manuscript.
And that's held in Ted
on just a few years ago.
And I've been involved in editing and
translating a few of these treatises. Um,
he's really interesting because he's
a Christian philosopher who lives in
Baghdad,
but he had Muslim colleagues who
are also members of the same school.
And we have an exchange between him and
a Jewish philosopher where the Jewish
scholar ask some
questions about Aristotle.
And yet you have an ID writes back and
explains the answer is that it's a really
good example of the way that philosophy
was a kind of three way interchange
between the three Abrahamic
faiths in the Islamic world.
Um, another thing I just
wanted to mention briefly,
although I've mentioned it in passing
before, is that this language of Syriac,
which is another,
as I said,
another Semitic language was not
only a kind of intermediary texts for
translating from Greek into Arabic,
but was actually used to write philosophy.
So there's another posts,
um,
host 1200 thinker by our brass
who actually wrote in Syriac.
Um,
and as I already mentioned,
a lot of important Jewish philosophers
lived in the Islamic world.
I've already mentioned my
monities, that's my monities. Um,
earlier on in the 10th century, there's
a philosopher names idea Gowan, uh,
who lived in Iraq and he,
when reason I want to
mention him is that he, when,
when you read his works,
he's commenting on the Hebrew Bible
from a kind of philosophical theological
point of view.
And some of the ideas he's using are
taken from the Greek Arabic translation
movements.
But other ideas come from this tradition.
And this is the last thing I
want to tell you still on time.
So column column is, uh, it means Xy,
Arabic word meaning word.
So it's the Arabic for word
and it is usually trend.
It's used to refer to an intellectual
tradition in the Islamic world,
which is sometimes translated as
rational theology or Islamic theology.
Uh,
but it may be important to say that,
I mean Cullen doesn't have anything to do
at analogically with the word theology,
which actually has a Greek
word originally. Whereas, um,
the group, the Arabic Word
for Philosophy is fun sofa.
So it's derived directly from
the Greek word for philosophy.
And there's a kind of,
I would say there's a sort of
quiet debate going on in my fields.
This is the kind of thing we
argue about at conferences.
I'm sure it's all fascinating and I'm
sure you're all really jealous about these
wonderful arguments we have over coffee.
Uh,
so there's a kind of debate going on
about whether the study of philosophy me,
Islamic world,
she didn't include this material
because there's a kind of whole separate
intellectual tradition,
this column tradition where what
they're doing is giving rational,
uh,
elucidations arguments and interpretations
of the Koran and other Islamic
materials.
So one way to think
about this is that it's,
it's very much like the fact
that in medieval Latin Europe,
a lot of the philosophers do theology.
So for example,
the most famous work of Thomas Aquinas,
who I've mentioned numerous times
is the summa Theologiae. This,
the summary or the,
the summa of theology.
And he was a theologian. There
was a, in the medieval university,
there was actually a faculty
called the theology faculty.
And most of the important medieval
Latin of philosophers were actually
theologians, professionally,
theologians. Um,
so my attitude about this effectively is,
well,
if we're willing to count people like
Aquinas and other medieval theologians as
philosophers, then we should count these
guys too. And in fact, I have a, uh,
sort of thought experiment
I'd like people to entertain,
which is imagine that they hadn't
translated our subtle into Arabic.
So you wouldn't have people like
[inaudible] who are primarily inspired by
Aristotle. All you would have
had is this, this Cullen stuff.
Well,
what would happen now when historians of
philosophy turned to the Islamic world
and looked for stuff to study,
they would just treat this as part of
the history of philosophy completely
unproblematically just as we treat
medieval Christian theology as part of the
history of philosophy.
But instead what we
get is that being part,
because there was this distinction in
the Islamic World Itself Between Fid Sofa
philosophy and kilohm theology,
um,
people trend to treat the,
the philosophy part,
the part that's inspired by Aristotle as
the real philosophy and this stuff not
as philosophy.
Um,
but I think this is just another way
of missing a bunch of philosophically
interesting material. And so, um,
this whole project that I have of trying
to fill in the gaps of the history of
philosophy to me means that you should
take things like [inaudible] seriously as
a part of the history of philosophy.
Also, by the way, things like Sufism,
which I also covered in the series and
even things like the physical sciences,
like theories of optics,
theories of physical motion and so on.
Um, I tried it and even
the history of mathematics,
I try to cover that in the
podcast series as well.
And a little bit in the very short
introduction. Okay. So just to wrap up,
um, the, what's the point of all this?
So as you might've been
able to tell by now,
I'm like really a history of
philosophy nerd. And in fact,
I mean the reason I do
the podcast in a way,
it's just kind of curiosity about
the history of philosophy. Um,
and for me,
the,
the point of it is to tell the history
of philosophy is one continuous story.
So a narrative that doesn't miss anything
out, but someone might say, well,
I'm not really interested in
about in that. Like I don't,
it's not like normal history where you
need to know each thing that happens.
What we should care
about is the big ideas,
the greatest figures
and what they have said.
So I'm perfectly happy
to be told about cons,
but I don't want to be told about all of
the other random little German figures
that contra was reading and responding
to you because they're probably quite
boring. Right? And this
is an, to be honest,
at least tacitly the attitude that
most historians of philosophy have,
if only because of lack
of time and energy.
But I think this is a mistake and there's
several reasons I think it's a mistake.
One is that if you do genuinely want to
understand someone like Plato or Aquinas
or cons, you had better know
what they were responding to.
And comment isn't responding to the last
most famous philosopher he's responding
to his contemporaries, people
in the previous generation, um,
dozens and dozens of authors
who are now forgotten.
And of course that's true for
everyone in the history of philosophy.
It's a lot like the history of art.
So if you go to museums,
there's like the really
famous people like Picasso,
but then in the same galleries there's
paintings by people you haven't
necessarily heard of.
And you can see that causes in dialogue
with these less famous people, right?
It's the same thing in the
history of philosophy. Um,
but in addition to that,
it's just not true that
the really interesting
philosophical ideas only turn up
in the most famous authors, they kind
of have a better hit rate, right?
There's more interesting
ideas per page maybe,
or they just have a larger
total number of great ideas.
And that's why we think they're so
awesome. But actually a lot of minor,
supposedly minor or lesser and
unfit years are just as interesting.
Like have a center for instance,
and even more minor figures may have a
brilliant argument or idea somewhere in
there. Otherwise rather derivative
and Turgid works, right?
So I think if what you're interested
in is finding good philosophy,
you should look everywhere
where it might be.
And you should take it wherever it comes,
even if it's in a work that's
primarily not a philosophical work,
like a theological work or a
mystical work. And the other thing,
which I haven't said very much about,
but if you want,
we can talk about it in the Q and a,
is um,
well how does all of this relate to what's
going on in the contemporary Islamic
world?
I mean,
I'm not an expert on contemporary
Islamic culture or politics,
but it does.
I mean,
even I can see that it's intuitive and
obvious in a way that if it philosophy in
the Islamic world had ended it in 1200,
it would be a very minimal relevance
for what's going on now. Right?
Because that was not very good at math.
You're probably all very good at math,
but it was a long time ago.
Right?
Whereas if we take seriously the idea
that philosophy in the Islamic world is a
kind of continuous tradition that
God does survive the death of,
of Airways and go on century after
century into empires like the Ottoman and
some of it empire whose political
structures still in a way structure the
contemporary political, uh, scene
in the Islamic world, then we,
that's a big step in the
direction of seeing how, um,
these historical traditions affect
the world we're living in today. Okay.
Thanks very much.
Thank you very much.
We do have time for questions.
Please wait for the microphone.
Yup.
Nope.
Nice. Very interesting
talking. And, um, uh,
we have been talking more
about the interaction with
west and the Arabic world.
And so what about in similar
kind of interaction that
happened to the east India
or a pushy or China?
We know that through the art,
through the mathematics,
a lot of interaction has happened.
So what about on the philosophical side?
Yeah. Uh, is there more specifically,
is there anything that has been,
um, but the Indian philosophy,
whether it has been influenced by
Arabic in a major Arab Islamic world
philosophy in some major way
and Robert's also, right.
Okay. Having heard about
anything like that, thank you.
Last part a little worse?
Or how would they can gain philosophy
affected or influenced on enhance the
Islamic world philosophy?
Okay.
Yeah. So, um, actually one of
the questions I get most often,
especially now that I'm doing podcasts
on Indian philosophy is whether Indian
philosophy was influenced by Greek
philosophy or vice versa. And I'm,
I tend to be a skeptic about that because
there's no Sanskrit Greek translation
movements or vice versa.
You get a lot of striking similarities.
For example, just to take one science
scientific example, um, there's a,
there's a, you know, there's a theory
of the four humors in ancient medicine,
blood bile and F. Dot. The two
kinds bile and phlegm, right,
which constitute the human body.
And there's a very similar
humoral theory in India,
although it's not the same humors
and there's five and not four.
So it doesn't match up exactly. But it
sort of makes you think, um, and there's,
and we also have very concrete cases where
Greek astronomy and astrology affects
India and vice versa. So that's
clear. Um, but I actually,
generally speaking,
I don't personally,
I don't think that the influence of
Indian philosophy on Greek philosophy was
strong if it was there at all. And
there were reverse as far as I can tell,
nothing. Okay. With Islam
it's very different.
So, so obviously first of all,
it's the Islamic world is,
is very different from India and China
because it's massively engaged with Greek
philosophy. As I've been saying. Uh,
it is also engaged with Indian culture.
So I mentioned data who he's really late,
so he's an interesting case.
But there's also a contemporary of
Addison is named [inaudible] who,
uh, in fact wrote an exchange
of letters with [inaudible].
Like the other one that I mentioned
where Bertone ass tricky questions about
science and philosophy and have
a center has to try to answer.
And Buitoni wrote a work called a hint,
meaning India in which he,
um, he's basically
interviewed, he lives on,
he lived very near India
and he's speaking to, um,
basically prisoners of war or
guests of the local warlord.
And he interviewed them about their
culture and wrote this huge work about
Indian culture and religion.
And it has some stuff about
philosophy and it as well. So, um,
that's an early case. That's, and that's,
uh, so that would be 10th, 11th century.
So it's around 1100. Um, no, sorry,
it's around. It's around 1080.
Uh, and, um, really from
that point on, you have a,
an interweaving of Indian
and Islamic culture.
And of course the Mughal empire is
an Indian empire that's Islamic.
So there's no doubt that,
um,
once you get past the kind of
formative early period of Islam,
you have a lot of interaction
between Islam and India. Uh,
prior to that, it's more minimal,
but you find very strong influence,
especially in the sciences, like
in astronomy, again. So, um,
if you look into Islamic
astronomy and astrology,
they make constant reference to Indian
theories of astronomy. And astrology,
they even talk about the Indian world
cycles and how long they are and things
like that. So there's plenty of evidence
for that for the Islam India exchange.
More questions.
Um,
one question that you mentioned, um,
just to expand a bit on the Africa side,
um, what is the connection or is there
a connection with the Islamic world,
especially with the library of
Alexandria and the Tunisian Center
and Sophie fluence when they
were under, um, the ultimate, uh,
occupation and basically, yeah.
Okay. So actually, I mean, just as,
um,
just as for a while,
Islam philosophy and Islamic world is
just part of Indian philosophy because the
moment,
I mean the mogul empire is Indian.
So the Ottoman Empire to a
larger extent is African. I mean,
not to a larger time that part of
its African. Right. And some of,
and I mentioned at least one thinker who
is from Africa named Nicole doing, uh,
so you have, so often people talk
about the mud, the Malcolm hub,
the western Islamic world, which for
a while of course included Spain.
And you can think about Islamic Spain,
northern Africa,
all the way over to Cairo,
to Egypt as a cultural unit,
which is the western analog to the
Islamic heartlands in basically Iraq and
Iran. And then if further into
Central Asia. Okay. So, um,
on the one hand, uh, so okay,
that's true for the Islamic world, but
also if you think about late antiquity,
the Roman Empire to a larger
extent is north African, right?
So one by the way,
one of my favorite tips to give people
is if you're ever playing 20 questions,
you know this game where you think
of someone, they have to, right?
So usually people will try to narrow
down who you're thinking of it by finding
out where they're from,
right?
Picked Saint Augustan because Saint
Augustan is from northern Africa,
right? If he's from Tunisia
and no one will ever get
that. So if they think, okay,
I'm trying to think of an African person,
they'll ever come up with Saint Augustan.
Uh,
of course now that we videoed
this and put it on the Internet,
it's not nearly as good at
Typ, but, okay. So, so, um,
and then you just mentioned
the library of Alexandria.
So that Alexandria is really the
last phase of philosophy muse in late
antiquity.
And when these guys translated
Greek philosophy into Arabic,
they aren't only translating
things like Aristotle,
they're translating the commentaries
written on our subtle in Alexandria.
So actually both in late antiquity, in
the, in the period of the Roman Empire.
And then also during the Islamic empire
is you have northern Africa completely
involved culturally.
And so it's actually not,
it's very unhelpful here to think as
we normally do about Europe because
actually what you've got
is a Mediterranean sphere,
which includes the Byzantine Empire in
that period as well until it falls to the
Ottomans.
And then you've got another sphere,
which is the Islamic East, which
actually is where most of the action is.
It philosophically, but not
all of the action. Um, so, uh,
really north African philosophy
is constantly involved in, in,
in fact,
one of the,
one of the things I've been talking to
with my future coauthor she k about is
how do we deal with the fact that I
already covered a bunch of African
philosophy because we're going to
start by talking about ancient Egypt's,
but I actually already covered a bunch
of African philosophers like these
Alexandria and commentators and Augustan.
So we're just going to kind
of mention that and say,
go listen to the old episode if you want
to know about that and then move on.
But you're right that,
that's completely integrated into
everything that I was just saying. Really.
So what are the different motives that
actually drove these philosophers to
actually go about their work?
So for example,
you mentioned some doing it for
purpose of debating religion,
say yeah. Um, whereas others may do it
just purely academically as it were. Yeah.
Yeah. So of course that varies
from thinker to thinker. Uh,
one thing that seems to have
happened, uh, in both the Latin,
medieval and medieval Islamic worlds,
is that you get a kind of
person who considers himself,
and it's always a him to be a
kind of professional philosopher.
So in a Latin medieval context,
it's not these theologians I've mentioned,
there was a theology of faculty.
There's also something called the arts
faculty where they taught students logic.
Um, and by the way, that
just interesting fact,
the students are teenagers.
The medieval universities student would
have been starting off at 13 or 14 and
they would be taught Aristotelian logic
and then they would move up and maybe
become a master at the university,
either of arts or theology.
And these arts guys,
we're not theologians.
And we're very clear that that's not
what they were doing. So for example,
there's a 14th century philosopher
named John Burden who just says, well,
I'm an arts master. I do logic
and physics. I do Aristotle,
I'm a specialist in Aristotle,
and this theology stuff is sort
of above my pay grade. Right?
And you've had the same kind of thing
going on in the Islamic world. So,
especially someone like [inaudible],
he,
he was actually a Muslim jurists as well.
But in his philosophical works,
he very explicitly presents himself as an,
as an expert on Aristotle who's
explaining, so it's like his,
his intellectual mission is to recover
and explain the teachings of Aristotle
because he just thinks Aristotle's
the greatest thinker has ever lived.
And then he, when he comes to think about
how that relates to the Koran, he says,
philosophers are the people in the best
position to interpret the Quran because
they already know what's true because
they have proofs and everyone else is just
kind of lost in the dark.
And they can,
and they should follow the
surface meaning of the Quran,
but they shouldn't really try to interpret
it because they'll just come up with
all kinds of wacky ideas, whereas
philosophers is actually know the truth.
And so they can sort of
explain how the Quran,
it's expressing something
they already know to be true.
So that's a very radical rationalist
projects. And it's unusual.
Most philosophers have a much more nuanced
view about the relationship between
philosophy and their Abrahamic faith,
whichever of the three that it is.
And they may or may not admit that there
are certain things you can know through
revelation that he wouldn't be
able to know through reason. Um,
but generally speaking,
uh, this may surprise you.
The philosophers and the Islamic world
in all three faiths tend to be more
rationalist than the ones in
medieval Europe. So you get very,
you very commonly got the idea that
you wind up with the same truth through
revelation or reason and they kind of
agree and there wasn't really much that
revelation will tell you that you wouldn't
already have known through philosophy.
I mean maybe like how many times a
day you should pray or something,
you wouldn't be able to figure that out,
but that God exists what God is like,
what his relationship to the universe
is like, what our soul is like,
what virtue is Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
This is all something they think they
can get through the Greek inspired
philosophical sources.
Yup.
Well with it.
Hm. I'm wondering if there are any, um,
Islamic world based researchers,
philosophers that are writing about the
history of philosophy in Islamic world,
because if you consider
yourself slightly western,
are there any biases that
you think you might have?
No doubt. Yeah. Um, yes,
definitely. And in fact,
one of the things,
so actually if we go back to my list,
um,
this guy,
the fifth one on the list and Melissa
data is still seen in Iran as a very major
thinker who's, uh, continues
to be studied seriously,
not as a kind of historical figure,
but as a serious source of
philosophical inspiration in Iran,
not so much in other parts of
the Islamic world. Um, I mean,
the situation in the Islamic world is
very complicated as you might imagine.
There's a lot of different cultures
and countries with different university
systems and so on.
Um,
but certainly there are many universities
and the Islamic world where they teach
column and philosophy and maybe
as two separate disciplines.
Um, and they do do a history of
philosophy. However, they all, of course,
they're also very interested
in European philosophy.
So one of the things that has happened
since the late 19th century is that
European ideas,
philosophical as well as scientific
ideas obviously have been. Um,
I mean actually there's kind of permanent
engagements between the Islamic world
and European thought, but,
but specifically European
philosophy. Like Satan,
Marxism for example,
has played a major role in generating
many of the political movements in the,
that we've seen in the Islamic world over
the last century, century and a half.
And that continues to be the case.
So historians of philosophy
there obviously pay more
attention to the history of
Islamic philosophy than we do,
but they pay a lot of attention to the
history of European philosophy as well.
Um,
something I'm not so sure about is whether
you'd find very many people there who
say, Oh, I'm just a historian,
which is kind of my, anyway,
that's my bias is this sort of pretense
of neutrality and like I'm a blank and
I'm just telling you what they thoughts
and I have no presuppositions or
philosophical bias. He's of my
own, which of course can't be true,
but sort of by definition I can't
tell you about the biases I have,
I'm not aware of. So what I'm trying
to do is be a kind of neutral.
I'm completely open minded interpreter
who is interested in everything and just
wants to explain it in as clear a
way as possible. That's my goal. Um,
but obviously I w I admit that I
can't possibly be attaining that,
but that's what I'm striving to do.
And I'm not sure you'd find too many
thinkers actually here or there who have
that sort of purely historical approach.
I mean,
most historians of philosophy wouldn't,
wouldn't readily admit
to that in Europe either.
So it's kind of an unusual stance.
We are unfortunately out of time.
Thank you very much. Thanks for coming.